c'est la bonne
pour son premier voyage dans un pays que
ne couvre pas les flics pavillon
britannique
la princesse elizabeth d'angleterre a
choisi la france et paris est paris dès
son arrivée a voulu démontrer la
sympathie de son peuple
accompagnée de son mari le duc
d'édimbourg l'héritière de la couronne
la plus lourde s'est d'abord rendu à
l'elysée où le président de la
république l'a salué au nom de la france
il lui a remis le grand cordon de la
légion d'honneur en même temps qu'il
décorait de la pâte guerre le duc
d'edimbourg
cette première visite faite aux plus
hauts magistrats du pays le couple
princier ans
des unes aux autres aussi solennelle et
plus émouvant remontant les champs
elysées la princesse se rendait au
milieu des acclamations d'un ferry qui
l'avait déjà adopté jusqu'à la tombe en
dioses de soldat inconnu ou accueillis
par le général giraud
elle s'inclinait devant la pierre qui
garde le plus obscur et le plus glorieux
des soldats
au musée galliera 800 ans de vie et la
anglais ont été réunies
que la princesse elisabeth devait
s'adresser au peuple de france dans sa
propre langue
tous les hommes qui ont le souci de
sauvegarder les principes
fabien reprises nous avons quant à paul
défendu au prix de notre son
le mono est venu et prendre leurs
horizons bien au delà de leur propre
foyer
il faut que nous puissions mettre en
commun les dons et les vertus qui
connote héritage le plus cher la france
et la grande-bretagne se doivent de
francs de la direction de ce mouvement
à l'heure des chefs est incomparable
dès lors quelle mesure en idées grande
sagesse et en expérience au cours de sa
visite à ses souvenirs sont aussi des
fois c'est portela
inceste guidés par un chef du protocole
au grâce suranné vers tout ce qui a été
pendant des siècles
lundi une possible compréhension
franco-britannique souvenir où l'eau de
forme du doigt recette tient sa place
dans l'entente cordiale
[Musique]
versailles
et à cette visite
[Applaudissements]
autour du palais des rois a fait à la
future reine d'angleterre un accueil
le souverain ne se montrerait insensible
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une police sans bienveillance exécutrice
par trop rigide dendre mal fondées n'a
permis de montrer de la princesse à
versailles que ces quelques scènes
rapides presque arraché par surprise le
public français britanniques le
regretteront avec nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
versailles fontainebleau paris
millimages maintenant flotteront autour
de ces noms dans le souvenir de la
princesse elizabeth
mais la plus belle des images ce sera
peut-être celle ci la descente d'un plug
aux flots cam entre dérive chargé
d'histoire où chaque siècle a sa place
où chaque pierre rappelle le times green
day ou une joie nationale la traversée
par sa très grande rue la scène de paris
plus de deux fois millénaire et qui
après avoir souvent frémit au nom
anglais a juste maintenant le plus beau
ciel du monde au plus noble des paysages
pour mieux recevoir une princesse
britannique sait que le temps a coulé
avec l'eau sous les ponts et que la
france peut dire à la pile de son
ex-adversaire princesse cette paire est
votre ami
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]